I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everybody. Hi everyone.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这个终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎，大家好。大家好。
Welcome to season two, episode three, Office Olympics. Yee-hoo! Guys, if I sound grouchy today, it's because I'm in hour four of a cleanse. I've never done one before. I think they're stupid. I don't know why I'm doing it. Angela, what are your thoughts on my cleanse? It's a bad idea.
欢迎收看第二季第三集《办公室奥运会》。耶胡！伙计们，如果我今天听起来很烦躁，那是因为我正在进行排毒饮食的第四个小时。我以前从未做过。我觉得这太蠢了。我不知道我为什么要这么做。安吉拉，你对我的排毒饮食有什么看法？这是一个糟糕的主意。
Why am I doing it? I don't know. I don't know. Whatever. I don't want a bunch of people writing in like to us being like, you guys, cleanses are good for you. But you know what? I just think they sound like a big pain in the ass.
我为什么要这么做？我不知道。我不知道。随便吧。我不想让一堆人写信给我们说，嘿，你们俩，排毒对身体有好处。但你知道吗？我只觉得这听起来真是个大麻烦。
Here's the thing. I was running out of the house this morning. I was late. I didn't have time to make my usual breakfast of scrambled eggs and sliced strawberries. I eat that every morning. Oh man. I love it. Didn't have time.
事情是这样的。我今天早上急急忙忙跑出家门。我迟到了。我没有时间做我通常的早餐：炒鸡蛋和切片草莓。我每天早晨都吃那个。哦天哪。我太喜欢了。没时间做。
But I remembered that about eight months ago, I ordered this five-day cleanse at the advice of one of my friends. Who's like healthy or something? Super healthy. Looks amazing. Skin is amazing. And I thought, well, maybe today's the day. Maybe this is a sign.
但我记起大约八个月前，在一个朋友的建议下，我订购了这个五天的排毒套餐。那个朋友看起来很健康什么的？超级健康。看起来棒极了。皮肤好得不得了。我想，也许今天就是日子。也许这是一个征兆。
So I just grabbed day one of the cleanse. It's like a little pre-package. You know, I had a nut bar for breakfast. She looks like she's going into outer space, you guys. I'm so angry. She has a little box. I'm mad. You've got like, it looks like compressed food.
所以我随手拿了排毒套餐的第一天。就像一个小预包装。你知道的，我早餐吃了一根坚果棒。你们看，她看起来像要去外太空。我太生气了。她拿出一个小盒子。我很生气。你带的那个，看起来像压缩食品。
Everything's freeze dried. Compressed food in this little foil packets. I've already, I guess, cheated. I hate that. I hate that I'm shaming myself over this thing already. But I'm having coffee. You're not supposed to have coffee on the cleanse. You're supposed to have tea.
每样东西都是冻干的。这些小铝箔袋里装的是压缩食品。我想我大概已经作弊了。我讨厌这样。我讨厌自己为这事已经感到羞愧了。但我正在喝咖啡。排毒期间是不准喝咖啡的。你本该喝茶的。
It's not even caffeinated tea. What am I supposed to do with that? What is wrong with these people? That's what I'm saying. I don't know. And I already decided I think I'm going to eat a full meal for dinner. I don't know. Well, I won't tell you what I brought for lunch.
甚至不是含咖啡因的茶。我拿着它能做什么？这些人脑子有病吧？这就是我想说的。我不知道。而且我已经决定今晚要吃一顿正餐。我不知道。好吧，我不告诉你我午饭带了什么。
What? Pasta? I brought pasta? Oh my gosh. I have like freeze dried soup to eat. I know. I know. You're going into outer space.
什么？意面？我带了意面？哦天哪。我还得吃那种冻干汤。我知道。我知道。你要去外太空了。
You're eating your packets. Why am I even saying I'm doing a cleanse when I've already planned to eat dinner tonight? I'm not doing. I'm kind of doing a cleanse. I hate to break it to you. What am I doing? You're not doing a cleanse. You were rushing and you grabbed your NASA packets because you bought them and you feel
你在吃你的那些小包。既然我今晚都已经计划好要吃晚饭了，我为什么还要说我在排毒？我根本没在做。我算是在进行排毒吧。恕我直言。我到底在干什么？你根本没在排毒。你刚才赶时间，顺手抓了你的NASA（美国宇航局）宇航员食品包，因为你买了它们，而且你觉得
bad that you bought them. That is it. And they've been sitting there. Yes. And also what I'm learning about you, Jenna, like I already knew this about you. But boy, am I learning it now being your business partner. Is that if your routine gets thrown, you love routine, it sends you into this like spiral where all of a sudden you're like, like if you're like, oh, I didn't get my scrambled
买完不用很内疚。就是这样。它们一直在那儿放着。没错。而且我也从你身上了解到了这一点，珍娜，虽然我以前对你就有这种了解。但天哪，现在作为你的商业伙伴，我算是彻底领教了。那就是如果你的日常生活规律被打破——你非常喜欢按部就班——这就会让你陷入一种螺旋式的失控状态，以至于突然之间你会觉得，比如如果你觉得，哦，我没吃成我的炒
eggs and my strawberries. Do you know what I'm going to do? I'm going to move to Arizona. What? It's so true. I've so thrown that I start to make really wackadoo decisions. Yeah. You make some big swings.
鸡蛋和草莓。你知道我要做什么吗？我要搬到亚利桑那州去。什么？真的太对了。我受到的打击太大了，以至于开始做出非常荒唐的决定。Yeah。你会做出一些极端的举动。
Okay. All right. Well, let's see how it goes today. Yeah. On that note. This episode, as I said, is Office Olympics written by Mike Scher and directed by Paul Feig. Yay.
好吧。好吧，让我们看看今天进展如何吧。Yeah。借此机会。正如我所说，这一集是《办公室奥运会》，由迈克·舒尔编剧，保罗·菲格导演。耶。
Let me give a summary. In this episode, Michael has to leave the office for the day to sign papers on his new condo. He's becoming a homeowner, everyone. Dwight goes with him, leaving Jim in charge, who decides to use the day to stage Office Olympics with the employees. Fast fact number one, Office Olympics was inspired by the King of the Hill Office Olympics. Yes.
让我来做个总结。在这一集中，迈克尔必须离开办公室一天，去为他的新公寓签署文件。各位，他要成为房主了。德怀特跟他一起去了，留下吉姆负责，吉姆决定利用这一天和员工们举办一场办公室奥运会。趣味冷知识一：《办公室奥运会》的灵感来源于《山丘之王》中的办公室奥运会。没错。
The writers on Greg's show, King of the Hill, created a real Office Olympics and that is what inspired our episode. Actually, Jenna, it wasn't the writers that invented the Office Olympics for King of the Hill. It was Tim Crosston, Greg's assistant. Oh. Tim Crosston was Greg Daniels' assistant. Tim is also a longtime friend of mine.
格雷格的节目《山丘之王》的编剧们创造了一场真正的办公室奥运会，正是这启发了我们这一集。事实上，珍娜，发明《山丘之王》办公室奥运会的并不是编剧。那是格雷格的助理蒂姆·克罗斯顿。哦。蒂姆·克罗斯顿是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的助理。蒂姆也是我的老朋友。
I've known him for years. And Tim and two other assistants are who set up the whole Office Olympics at King of the Hill. The writers, yes, participated, Jenna. Okay. They participated. But it was a, Tim was the mastermind. He was the self-appointed commissioner.
我认识他好多年了。蒂姆和其他两位助理在《山丘之王》里一手策划了整个办公室奥运会。编剧们，是的，他们也参与了，珍娜。好吧。他们参与了。但这是一个，蒂姆才是幕后主脑。他是自封的委员。
Oh. Yes. And I- He was the gym. He was the gym. And I talked to him last night. We traded text messages and Tim, sorry if I woke you up at 11 o'clock at night in North Carolina, but thank you for responding.
哦。是的，而且我——他就是吉姆。他就是吉姆。我昨晚还和他通过话。我们互发了短信，蒂姆，如果我在北卡罗来纳州时间晚上11点把你吵醒了，我很抱歉，但谢谢你回复我。
They had a whole opening ceremonies. They had a torch. They had shirts for different teams. What? Yeah. They marched through the hallways. They had like a banner each team carried. They had a full opening ceremonies.
他们举办了完整的开幕式。他们有火炬。他们有不同队伍的队服。什么？是的。他们列队走过走廊。每个队伍都扛着一面旗帜。他们举办了完整的开幕式。
And you know the doves that you see at the end for our closing ceremonies? Yes. They had that. They had doves that went across. They had several games that they had to play. It took a day and a half, this Office Olympics. What were they not doing during this day and a half? I know.
你知道我们在闭幕式最后看到的那些鸽子吗？是的。他们也有那个。他们有飞过会场的鸽子。他们有几个必须要玩的游戏。这场办公室奥运会持续了一个半天。在这一个半天里，他们到底什么正事都没干吗？我知道。
Well, Tim said that we wasted a full day and a half on this and I won the award for wasting the most office time. So he said, so overall, I'm very proud of my time on King of the Hill. He said some of the games they had were mini golf through the office, Kerplunk, which was like this game, I guess where they had like sticks like in like a tube and you drop marbles down and then you had to twist it. I don't know. And then it went Kerplunk.
嗯，蒂姆说我们在这上面浪费整整一个半天，而我获得了“浪费最多办公时间奖”。所以他说，总的来说，我对我在《山丘之王》的那段时光感到非常骄傲。他说他们有的游戏包括办公室迷你高尔夫，还有一种叫“轰隆”（Kerplunk）的游戏，大概是那种他们把棍子插在一个管子里，然后把弹珠倒进去，接着你必须扭动它。我也不懂。然后它就会发出一声“轰隆”。
Tim's favorite game that they had though was guess the elevator and that made it into our episode. Yes. So someone went down to the lobby and then came up and you had to guess which elevator they came out. So he said that was his personal favorite. They also had a Twinkie eating contest and Paul Lieberstein came in second. Go Paul.
不过蒂姆最喜欢的游戏是“猜电梯”，这个游戏也进入了我们的这一集。是的。所以有人去大厅然后上来，你必须猜他们是从哪部电梯出来的。所以他说这是他个人的最爱。他们还有吃糖人的比赛，保罗·利伯斯坦得了第二名。为保罗加油。
Cause Paul was working on King of the Hill at the time as well, but he said they really got into it. They went all out and he said one of the things that blew him away was Chuck Manjoni. He is a famous musician, composer, Jenna. He actually played a recurring character on King of the Hill as himself as the celebrity spokesperson for the Megalomart. Yes. And he flew himself out on his own dime to play.
因为保罗当时也在《山丘之王》工作，但他说他们真的全身心投入了。他们全力以赴，他说其中一个让他大跌眼镜的人是查克·曼乔尼。珍娜，他是一位著名的音乐家、作曲家。他实际上在《山丘之王》里客串了一个常驻角色，扮演他自己，也就是美格罗超市（Megalomart）的名人代言人。是的。而且他自掏腰包飞来这里参与演出。
He plays the flugelhorn and the trumpet to play at the opening ceremonies because he in fact actually played at the Olympics in Lake Placid, New York. This is crazy. How many years did they do this? Do we know? This was an annual thing, right? I don't know that. I don't know that.
他吹奏弗鲁格号和小号来为开幕式配乐，因为他实际上真的在纽约普莱西德湖奥运会上演奏过。这太疯狂了。他们连续办了几年？我们知道吗？这是一年一度的活动吗？我不知道这个。我不知道。
I think, I mean, from what Tim texted me, they definitely went full out one year. I don't know if they could sustain this because I think they did waste a lot of time not working. And here's a random piece of trivia for you. I did a voice on King of the Hill. I had like a one line in the Megalomart where I said, wait, I don't sell superscourters no more on account of their dangers. So there's my, there's my connection there. Can you believe that?
我想，根据蒂姆发给我的短信，他们确实有一年是全力以赴的。我不知道他们是否能将之维持下去，因为我觉得他们确实浪费了很多时间没工作。这里有个随性的冷知识送给你。我在《山丘之王》里配过音。我在美格罗超市里有一句台词，我说：“等等，由于存在危险，我不再卖超级冲水枪了。”所以这就是我的，这就是我的渊源所在。你敢相信吗？
They really went all out on King of the Hill for their office Olympics. And that was the inspiration for office Olympics on the office. I love all of that information. That was amazing. Also, this episode ended up inspiring offices around the country to do their own office Olympics. I mean, this got even bigger than just our TV show. Tim, you really started something.
他们在《山丘之王》里为了他们的办公室奥运会真的是全力以赴。而那正是《办公室》中办公室奥运会的灵感来源。我喜欢所有这些信息。太精彩了。此外，这一集最终激发了全国各地的办公室去举办他们自己的办公室奥运会。我的意思是，这甚至超出了我们电视剧本身的规模。蒂姆，你真的开创了先河。
Thank you for that legacy. And thank you for letting me text you till almost midnight last night, your time. Fast fact number two, writer Mike Schur makes a cameo appearance in this episode. Oh yeah. Appearing in a photograph as Dwight's Amish cousin, Moes. Moes was actually based on a character in the UPN show, Amish in the city. It came out July, 2004, Jenna, I went down the rabbit hole last night and I watched the pilot episode of Amish in the city cause I wanted to see what the character of Moes.
谢谢你留下的这份传奇。也谢谢你让我昨晚能给你发短信发到将近午夜，按照你那里的时间。趣味冷知识二：编剧迈克·舒尔在这一集中客串出演。哦，是的。他以一张照片的形式出现，扮演德怀特的阿米什表哥莫斯（Moes）。莫斯这个角色实际上是以UPN电视台节目《城里的阿米什人》中的一个角色为原型的。该节目于2004年7月首播，珍娜，我昨晚深入研究了一番，看了《城里的阿米什人》的试播集，因为我想看看莫斯这个角色……
There is a guy named Moes. First of all, the premise for the show is crazy. They take five Amish teens who are on their rum, springa, you know, they can go and live in the world for a year and then they, in the non Amish world. And then they decide if they want to actually take the Amish way of life, right? So they take five Amish teens and they put them in a house in Los Angeles, like right off Ventura Boulevard, overlooking the city. And they put five mainstream American like teenagers.
里面有一个叫莫斯的家伙。首先，这个节目的设定太疯狂了。他们找了五个正在经历“出奔期”（rumspringa）的阿米什青少年，你知道的，他们可以去外面的世界生活一年，然后他们，在非阿米什人的世界里。接着他们决定是否真的要回归阿米什人的生活方式，对吧？所以他们找了五个阿米什青少年，把他们安排在洛杉矶的一栋房子里，就在文图拉大道（Ventura Boulevard）旁，俯瞰着整座城市。他们还安排了五个主流的美国青少年。
And now I think just taking five Amish kids to Los Angeles is enough. You got to throw in, there's a guy from Boston who's like, all I want to do was like, get laid and potty. Woohoo. And you're going to put him with Moes, Moes who like brought his wooden puzzles that he made himself. I mean, there's a whole scene where he's like, do you like puzzles? And the Boston guy's like, nah, I don't like them.
现在我觉得，光是把五个阿米什孩子带到洛杉矶就已经够疯狂了。你还得加上一个来自波士顿的家伙，他满脑子想的就是：“我只想泡妞和开派对。呜呼！”而你要把他和莫斯安排在一起——那个甚至带了他自己做的木制拼图的莫斯。我的意思是，里面有一整幕，他在问：“你喜欢拼图吗？”那个波士顿来的家伙说：“才不，我不喜欢。”
And he's like, oh, that's pretty much all I brought. Oh my gosh. This, okay. Sorry. Your explanation of Amish in the city is making me want to watch Amish in the city. I'm very invested in Moes. I feel like I'm going to have to go back because I'm like, what happened to Moes in his puzzles? How's he doing?
然后莫斯说：“哦，那这几乎是我带的全部东西了。”哦天哪。这，好吧。抱歉。你对《城里的阿米什人》的解释让我好想去看《城里的阿米什人》。我对莫斯非常感兴趣。我觉得我不得不回头去补一下，因为我在想：莫斯和他的拼图后来怎么样了？他现在过得好吗？
Well, I guess the writers were obsessed with Amish in the city as well. And the entire first season of the office, they would all talk about it. And so finally, when we got a season two, they, that was their way of honoring their love of Amish in the city was this character of Moes that Mike sure, I think he thought he was just appearing in a photograph, little did he know he would go on to play this character for nine years. And then probably would have been in the spin off the farm had it happened. True.
嗯，我猜编剧们对《城里的阿米什人》也是着迷得不行。在《办公室》的第一季期间，他们总是在讨论这个。所以最后，当我们迎来第二季时，他们，这就是他们向对《城里的阿米什人》的热爱致敬的方式，也就是迈克·舒尔塑造的莫斯这个角色。我想他当时以为自己只是出现在一张照片里，万万没想到他会连续九年出演这个角色。而且如果衍生剧《农场》拍成了的话，他很可能也会参演。确实。
He would still be playing Moes. Of course. We also introduced another recurring character in this episode. It is the realtor. Yes. Carol Stills. Carol Stills, played by Nancy Carell, Steve Carell's wife. Who is hilarious?
他大概到现在还在演莫斯呢。当然。我们在这一集中还引入了另一个常驻角色。那就是房产经纪人。是的。卡尔·斯蒂尔斯（Carol Stills）。由南希·卡瑞尔（Nancy Carell）饰演，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的妻子。她非常搞笑吗？
Nancy is hilarious. And we will talk more about her scenes with Steve as we get into this episode. Fact number three, this was our first time working with director Paul Feig, who is undoubtedly one of our favorite directors. Paul is so brilliant. And what I love is he's kind. He's just a delightful person to be around. We've talked a little bit about how he and his wife Lori would host our viewing parties,
南希太搞笑了。等我们聊到这一集时，我们会更多地谈到她和史蒂夫的对手戏。冷知识三：这是我们第一次与导演保罗·菲格（Paul Feig）合作，毫无疑问，他也是我们最喜欢的导演之一。保罗太才华横溢了。而我最喜欢的是，他为人很善良。他是一个相处起来非常令人愉快的人。我们之前稍微聊过他和他的妻子洛瑞是如何主持我们的追剧派对的，
but this was our first time working with him. And I'll never forget when he walked on set because he was wearing a full suit and tie. Oh, he is so dapper. Which he wore every day. Every day. Every day he wore a suit. A lot of them were like vintage suits, so they were also super cool. They weren't stuffy.
但这是我们第一次和他合作。我永远不会忘记他走进片场时的样子，因为他穿着一身全套西装和领带。哦，他太衣冠楚楚了。他每天都穿西装。每天。他每天都穿西装。其中很多还是那种复古西装，所以也超级酷。一点也不古板。
I mean, they were like super hip. No, he and his wife Lori are like, they're like a smart looking couple. Yeah. They look like people who read The New Yorker, don't they? Like they're super smart. They can read the long articles because those articles are super long. They're really smart. And their house, I remember, was like decorated, like so lovely.
我的意思是，它们简直时髦极了。不，他和他的妻子洛瑞看起来，他们就像是一对很有品味的时髦夫妇。是的。他们看起来就像是会读《纽约客》杂志的人，对吧？就像他们超级聪明。他们能阅读那些长篇大论的文章，因为那些文章真的超级长。他们真的很聪明。而且我记得他们的房子，装修得，简直太温馨了。
They had art. Yes. Yes. Art. But they're not stuffy people. You know what I mean? They're incredibly approachable. Not flashy.
他们家里有艺术品。是的。是的，有艺术品。但他们并不是那种古板的人。你知道我的意思吗？他们极其平易近人。一点也不张扬。
Yeah, not flashy. They're just really nice people. And Paul was one of my absolute favorite directors we ever had. You are in love with his Instagram. I am. She is obsessed with his Instagram. I love his Instagram. It makes me want to travel and dress nice and have a cocktail.
对，不张扬。他们真的是很好的人。而且保罗是我曾经合作过的绝对最喜欢的导演之一。你对他的Instagram（照片墙）简直爱得深沉。我是。她对他的Instagram着迷得不行。我太爱他的Instagram了。它让我想要去旅行、穿得漂亮、喝一杯鸡尾酒。
Yes. Yes, this is true. Sophie, before this, had worked on Freaks and Geeks, which I was a huge fan of. And actually, Freaks and Geeks is the very first television show I ever auditioned for. I wondered if you auditioned for that. That seemed like right in your wheelhouse. I did not audition for one of the regular characters. The show had already happened.
是的，没错，索菲在拍这个之前，曾参与过《怪胎与书呆子》（Freaks and Geeks）的工作，我是这部剧的超级粉丝。事实上，《怪胎与书呆子》是我这辈子去试镜的第一部电视剧。我很想知道你有没有去试镜过那部剧。那听起来完全符合你的戏路。我试镜的不是常规角色。这部剧当时已经开拍了。
But I went in for a guest appearance, I think just three lines. And this was because Alison Jones, who cast The Office, also cast Freaks and Geeks. This started my relationship with Alison Jones. I went in, I auditioned for Freaks and Geeks, I did not get the role. That's all right, lady. That's all right. It happens sometimes. She called me back later for a TV show called Undeclared that was produced by Judd Apatow.
但我去试镜了一个客串角色，我想只有三句台词。这是因为选角导演阿莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones）——她负责《办公室》的选角——也负责《怪胎与书呆子》。这开启了我与阿莉森·琼斯的合作关系。我去了，我为《怪胎与书呆子》试镜了，但我没得到那个角色。没关系，姑娘。没关系。这种事时有发生。她后来叫我回去为一个叫《主权在我》（Undeclared）的电视剧试镜，该剧由贾德·阿帕图（Judd Apatow）制作。
And I did get that part, just one line. And then, you know, five years later, she called me to audition for The Office. Wow. That was all Alison Jones. But I almost worked with Paul Feig on Freaks and Geeks, but it didn't happen. But it was meant to be, our paths would cross. Little did I know. And they did.
我确实拿到了那个角色，只有一句台词。然后，你知道的，五年后，她打电话叫我去为《办公室》试镜。哇。全都是托了阿莉森·琼斯的福。但我差一点就能在《怪胎与书呆子》里和保罗·菲格合作了，不过没能实现。但这一切都是命中注定，我们的轨迹终究会交汇。我当时万万没想到。后来确实交汇了。
But, you know, Paul also directed Bridesmaids, one of my all-time favorite movies. So funny. I remember going to that premiere because, you know, we were so excited to support Paul and to support Ellie and the whole cast was just phenomenal. And I was so happy for him. And you know, Paul is the type of guy, the minute he sees you, this huge smile comes across his face and he gives you a big hug. And he's just such a giving person of his self, you know?
但是，你知道的，保罗还导演了《伴娘》（Bridesmaids），那是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一。太搞笑了。我记得我去参加那部电影的首映礼，因为，你知道的，我们非常高兴能去支持保罗，支持埃莉，整个演员阵容简直无与伦比。我为他感到由衷的高兴。而且你知道的，保罗就是那种人，他一见到你，脸上就会绽放出灿烂的笑容，并给你一个大大的拥抱。他是一个非常慷慨、乐于付出的人，你知道吗？
And I was so happy to support him and so happy that it ended up being such a huge hit. I want to call your attention to Paul Feig's many books that are amazing, okay? He wrote Kick Me, which is, I guess it's like his autobiography for the first chapter of his life. Yes. About his adolescence. Yeah. I really feel like he could write a whole bunch more.
我很高兴能去支持他，也很高兴这部电影最终能取得如此巨大的成功。我想提醒大家注意保罗·菲格写的那些精彩绝伦的书，好吗？他写了《踢我》（Kick Me），我想这可以算是他人生前半段的自传。是的，关于他的青春期。Yeah。我真的觉得他还能再写一大堆。
But he's so funny. The book is amazing. And then he also wrote this book called Super Stud or How I Became a 24-Year-Old Virgin. It's also amazing. So you guys, really, if you want to dive deep on Paul Feig, I recommend these books. Guess what we did? We called Paul Feig for this episode. Who is singing?
但他太搞笑了。这本书太棒了。然后他还写过一本书叫《超级种马，或者我是如何成为一个24岁处男的》（Super Stud or How I Became a 24-Year-Old Virgin）。这本书也同样精彩。所以伙计们，真的，如果你想深入了解保罗·菲格，我强烈推荐这些书。你们猜我们做了什么？我们为这一集给保罗·菲格打了电话。谁在唱歌？
What has this cleansed onto me? It's turned me into you. It's turning you into me and you're about to make some crazy life choices. Should we go to a bar right now? No, God, no. We should not. That's horrible. It's 11 a.m. also.
这个排毒饮食对我都做了些什么？它把我变成了你！它正在把你变成我，而你马上就要做出一些疯狂的人生抉择了。我们现在应该去酒吧吗？不，上帝啊，不，我们绝对不该去。太可怕了。而且现在才早上11点。
Probably defeats the purpose of your cleanse. Guys, we called Paul Feig and we interviewed him about Office Olympics. We even included some of your questions. So after the break, we're going to talk to Paul Feig. We're going to ask him some questions. He's going to tell us about Office Olympics. I can't wait. All right.
那可能就违背了你排毒的初衷了。伙计们，我们给保罗·菲格打了电话，并就《办公室奥运会》采访了他。我们甚至还加入了你们的一些提问。所以在中场休息之后，我们要和保罗·菲格聊聊天。我们要问他一些问题。他会给我们讲讲《办公室奥运会》的故事。我等不及了。好的。
Stay tuned. All right. We are back and we are going to be talking to Paul Feig. Sam, dial him up. Hello. Hi, Paul. Hey, Paul. How are you?
请继续收听。好啦。我们回来了，接下来我们要和保罗·菲格聊聊天。萨姆，给他拨号。喂？嗨，保罗。嗨，保罗。你好吗？
I'm good. How are you? Are you somewhere fancy, Paul? No. I'm in New York, actually. Yeah. But are you somewhere fancy? Well, my apartment's very fancy.
我很好。你呢？保罗，你现在是在什么很豪华的地方吗？没有。其实我在纽约。不过你是在什么豪华的地方吗？嗯，我的公寓非常豪华。
Because I'm very fancy. Thank you so much for doing this. Paul, it really means a lot. Oh, my God. I'm so excited. I'm so happy that you guys are doing this. And I wish I could be in the studio with you. It would be so much even more fun.
因为我这个人非常讲究。非常感谢你百忙之中抽出时间。保罗，这真的对我们意义重大。哦，天哪。我太激动了。我很高兴你们在做这个播客。我真希望我也能和你们一起在录音室里。那样一定会更有趣得多。
Well, you're always welcome to come back. We've got 200 episodes to talk about. And you directed a great deal of them. Oh, good. Exactly. I'll talk on all of mine. We'll hit you up for that. We actually reached out to some fans to talk to you today.
随时欢迎你回来。我们有200集的内容要聊呢。而且你导演了其中很大一部分。哦，太好了。没错。我会把我导演的那几集都聊个遍的。到时候我们会找你来聊的。我们其实联系了一些粉丝，让他们今天向你提问。
And there were people who had so many questions. Yeah. So we're going to include some of their questions with our questions. Very good. I'm excited. Well, to get started, Paul, how did you get involved with the office?
有好多人提出了非常多的问题。Yeah。所以我们要把他们的一些问题和我们的问题结合起来。太好了。我很兴奋。保罗，首先，你是怎么加入《办公室》剧组的？
It was my great agent at the time, Rene Kurtz, who was steering me towards it. Honestly, I was offered several years before the chance to develop the office, the British office, into a series. And I was like, oh, forget it. There's no way you can do it. It's too scary because it's such a great series. So I just didn't even take the bait.
当时我有一位非常优秀的经纪人叫勒内·库尔茨（Rene Kurtz），是她在指引我往这方面发展。老实说，在好几年前，我就曾被邀请过把《办公室》，也就是英版《办公室》开发成一个系列剧。当时我想，哦，算了吧。根本没法做。这太吓人了，因为原版是一部如此优秀的剧集。所以我甚至连诱饵都没咬。
But then when Greg did it, I was really amazed by that. And actually, the funny thing is I was making a pilot at the same time that Greg did the pilot for the office. And I remember we were both working at some studio, and he was editing there. And I remember him coming over to us to Rodney Rothman and I, whose pilot it was. And he's like, hey, come in here.
但后来当格雷格把它做出来时，我真的感到非常惊艳。其实，有趣的是，在格雷格制作《办公室》试播集的同一时期，我也在制作一部试播集。我记得我们当时都在某个片场工作，他当时在那里做剪辑。我记得他朝我们走过来，走向罗德尼·罗斯曼（Rodney Rothman）和我——那是我们当时制作的试播集的导演，他说：“嘿，进来。进来。我得放一首我刚刚导演的这部剧的片头曲的几个不同备选版本给你们听听。”
Come in here. I got to play you a couple of different options for the opening theme song for this show that I just directed. And so he played a couple of different versions, including the one that would be now infamous piano one. So I was definitely there right at the very beginning. When the show got picked up, my agent called me, Rene, and she was just like, they'd like you to direct an episode.
于是他播放了几个不同的版本，包括现在已经家喻户晓的那首钢琴曲版本。所以我绝对是从最一开始就在那里见证了。当这部剧被电视台买下后，我的经纪人勒内打电话给我，她就说：“他们想让你导演一集。”
And so I watched the first six that you guys had done and thought they were so hilarious. You know, as soon as I saw Diversity Day, I was just like completely in. I just thought it was so great. Yeah, I came to that first table read. I don't know if you remember, they did kind of a bunch of episodes all at once.
于是我看了你们拍的前六集，觉得它们太搞笑了。你知道的，我一看到《多元化日》（Diversity Day）那一集，就彻底入坑了。我只是觉得它太棒了。Yeah，我去了第一次剧本围读会。我不知道你记不记得，他们当时好像是一口气读了好几集的剧本。
And I remember you guys were reading the Dundee's and all that. And then we read Office Olympics. And so I was in. Did you get to pick Office Olympics from that table read? Or was it assigned to you? Yeah, that was the one that was assigned to me because I remember having a moment going like, oh, I want to do the
我记得你们当时在读《达迪奖》（The Dundies）那一集以及所有那些内容。然后我们读了《办公室奥运会》。于是我就彻底加入进去了。你是从那次剧本围读会上挑中了《办公室奥运会》吗？还是说那是分配给你的？Yeah，那是分配给我的，因为我记得当时心里闪过一个念头：“哦，我想拍《达迪奖》。
Dundee's. That seems really fun. But then, um, but then I just saw the potential of the Office Olympics was just, was just going to be such a, such a blast. I mean, it was, it was just, it was just such a fun thing to kind of put together. I mean, I remember just what an interesting, I don't know,
那看起来真的很有趣。”但随后，嗯，但随后我看到了《办公室奥运会》蕴含的潜力，它绝对，绝对会是一次无比欢乐的体验。我的意思是，这简直，这简直是一件太有趣的事情，可以把它拼凑并展现出来。我的意思是，我记得当时片场有一种多么有趣的，
what interesting feeling it was on the set for that, because I mean, if you remember, that was sort of, you know, aside from the Olympics part of it, that was the episode that kind of started to turn everything because that's where, you know, Steve's character started to become slightly more sympathetic. And I don't know if you remember or not, we really, that kind of got found on the set.
我不知道，多么奇妙的氛围，因为我的意思是，如果你还记得的话，那可以说是，（除了奥运会的部分之外）那一集是开始让一切发生转折的一集，因为那是史蒂夫的角色开始变得稍微多了一点同情心的地方。我不知道你还記不记得，我们真的是在片场自然而然地发现了这一点。
Because remember, we were doing the whole thing where we were presenting, you guys were presenting Michael with the, you know, the, with the, the metal. And Steve just made this decision to kind of start crying. Yeah. You know, getting all choked up. And, and I remember just going like, oh my God, Steve, that's so great.
因为你还记得吗，我们在拍那场戏的时候，你们大家正在为迈克尔颁发那个，你知道的，那个奖牌。而史蒂夫当时就临时决定开始哭泣。Yeah。你知道的，哽咽了起来。我记得当时我心里就在想：“哦，天哪，史蒂夫，这太棒了。”
Like, keep going with that. And that was, I think that was kind of the, the turning point where his character took that left turn from Ricky Gervais' character and became more sort of the, the lovable, you know, misfit who's trying too hard for everybody to like him. And all I remember in that filming of that scene that you directed all of us to be genuine.
“就这样继续演下去。”我认为这就是那个转折点，他的角色从里奇·热维斯（Ricky Gervais）的角色风格中来了个急转弯，转变成了那种可爱又有点，你知道的，笨拙的人，他只是太努力想让所有人都喜欢他。而且我记得在拍摄那场你指导我们所有人都必须表现得真诚的那场戏时，
And you can see it on our faces that we are genuinely clapping for Michael. We're not mocking him. It was this collective moment with everyone in the office enjoying supporting one another. It was really sweet. It makes me tear up every time I watch it. I cried when Steve did that.
你可以从我们的脸上看出，我们是真心实意地在为迈克尔鼓掌。我们不是在嘲笑他。那是办公室里的每个人都在享受并支持彼此的一个集体时刻。真的非常温馨。每次我看这一幕时，都会感动得落泪。史蒂夫那样演的时候，我都哭了。
Yeah. It really gets me too. Cause I think, you know what it was, it was just Steve's performance was so sincere that it felt, if we were kind of being snarky or, or, or, you know, laughing at him, that it made us such, it made you guys such villains to do that. And, you know, and it was, but it wasn't anybody's really instinct to do that.
Yeah。我也总是被触动。因为我觉得，你知道那是为什么吗？因为史蒂夫的表演是如此真诚，以至于如果我们表现得尖酸刻薄，或者，或者，你知道的，在嘲笑他的话，那就会把你们衬托得像是一群大反派。而且，你知道的，当时其实没有人有那种恶意的本能。
And so I just, just kind of encourage you to, to go along with what you were already doing, which is we were all really being affected by Steve. Yeah. Yeah. It still gets me. Well, we have a fan question for you. Um, Reed wrote in and said, I know, ooh, Reed says, when
所以我只是鼓励你们顺着你们已经在做的事情继续演下去，那就是我们所有人都真的被史蒂夫的表演给打动了。Yeah。Yeah。现在想起来还是让我很感动。好吧，我们有一个粉丝提问要问你。嗯，里德（Reed）发信来问，我知道，噢，里德说，当
filming a mockumentary, do you storyboard or do you have a shot plan? Neither. What you do is you basically kind of go through the script and I would walk around with Kelly, our AD, the, you know, the day before or whatever. And we just basically kind of go, okay, what's the bet? Where would we put the cameras for this scene so that we
拍摄伪纪录片时，你们会画分镜头脚本吗，还是会有一个镜头拍摄计划？两个都没有。你所做的基本上就是通读一遍剧本，然后我会和凯莉——我们的第一副导演——在前一天或者什么时候一起四处走走。我们基本上就是说：“好吧，赌注是什么？我们把这个场景的摄像机放在哪里，
would be cross shooting it and the cameras could, could avoid seeing each other, but where the documentary crew would actually be. And, um, so you always just kind of going, okay, you know, for me, it's like, I always want to have depth behind us. So I never wanted to shoot in the walls whenever I could avoid it. And so just kind of go, okay, you, they would be, you know,
这样我们就能进行交叉拍摄，摄像机可以避开彼此的视线，同时又能符合纪录片摄制组实际所在的位置。”而且，嗯，所以你总是会想：“好吧，对我来说，我总是希望我们的背景有深度。”所以只要能避免，我永远不想对着墙壁拍摄。于是我就去琢磨：“好吧，你们会，你知道的，
one would be over here by this desk and then on the opposite side, something, you know, Matt would be over there and Randall would be on the other side. And really that was, that was kind of it. Then you'd also go like, okay, is this going to be a spy shot where you guys don't know you're on camera? Well, we'll be shooting through, you know, the blinds are through a crack in the door.
一个机位会在那边这张桌子旁，然后在对面的某个位置，你知道的，马特会在那边，兰德尔会在另一边。”真的，基本上就是这样。然后你还会想：“好吧，这会是一个偷拍镜头吗，就是你们不知道自己在被拍摄？好吧，我们会透过，你知道的，百叶窗或者门缝去拍。”
Um, and then that was kind of it. And then, then we would just get there and just play out the scene. For me, this is, it's the greatest way to do TV comedy because it just, every time we shot the scene, we had the full scene. And so it just allowed us to just play and go like, okay, this time try this, you know, and, you know, and just the
嗯，基本上就是这样。然后，然后我们就会到片场，直接把这场戏演出来。对我来说，这是拍摄电视喜剧最棒的方式，因为每一次我们拍这个场景时，我们都有完整的场景。所以这让我们能够尽情发挥，心想：“好吧，这次试试这个，”你知道的，
fact that Greg and everybody let us play around so much with these great scripts that we already had. And, and then we had the confidence to keep that stuff in because I'd worked on other shows where the cast was really brilliant at kind of improving or tagging something or just kind of taking a little left turn in the middle of the scene. But the show runners just wouldn't put it in because they
而且，你知道的，格雷格和所有人允许我们在我们已经拿到的优秀剧本的基础上进行那么多的即兴发挥，
were so in love with their scripts that they just wouldn't use it. But, you know, just, I mean, the, the shining example of that was when we did the next episode, the Halloween episode where we had that thing where we found, where Rain was doing, you know, playing the emperor and talking to Michael and kind of goading him. And we just found that funny angle that looked like the
这本身就是一个极其闪亮的例子，那就是当我们拍摄下一集——也就是万圣节那一集时，我们有这样一个情节：我们发现雷恩正在扮演皇帝，与迈克尔对话并挑衅他。我们恰好找到了那个有趣的拍摄角度，看起来就像《星球大战》里的皇帝，你只能看到他的脸。我们看着他不断地挑衅。那一幕持续了很久很久。但我认为格雷格舍弃了其他的一些故事情节，只是为了让我们能把那个场景保留得长一点，因为它实在是太搞笑了。而且，你知道的，这需要，这需要付出极大的
emperor from, from Star Wars where you just kind of see his face. And we just, you know, him just taunting. That went on and on. But Greg, I think, Jettison, some other kind of storyline just so we could keep that scene long because it was just so funny. And, you know, that, that, that takes, that takes a lot of
自信，在某种程度上，真的是导演兼制片人自身的自信，才能让那些精彩的时刻这样发展下去。我太喜欢这个了。我也是。我喜欢听所有关于最终呈现于银幕之上的幕后故事。我们当时只是在演戏。
confidence in, in sort of, you know, well, self-confidence really on the part of the showrunner to let those moments play out like that. I love that. Me too. I love hearing everything that went into the, how it ended up on screen. We were just acting.
你却做了这么多的规划。我知道。你在这上面倾注了所有的心血。没有你，我们什么都不是。没有你，我们什么都不是。我想请你稍微谈谈这一集中挑选公寓外景的事，因为它几乎就像另一个角色。
You did all this planning. I know. You put all this thought into it. Without you, we are nothing. Without you, we are nothing. I'm wondering if you can talk a little bit about picking the condo location in this episode because it's almost like another character.
它的戏份太突出了。挑选这套公寓的标准是什么？你想要一个空间流动感和开阔感足够好的地方，这样你们就不会被困在小房间里，你知道的，背景里除了墙壁什么都没有。所以我真正喜欢它的一点是，它有一个直通后天井的厨房。
It features so prominently. What was the criteria for picking the condo? You wanted something that, that had enough flow to it and openness that you weren't going to be stuck in little rooms, you know, with, with just basically walls as your background. And so what I really liked about it is they had that kitchen that went through to the back patio.
所以，你知道的，我们在厨房里拍摄迈克尔情绪崩溃的戏，这可能仍然是我在片场笑得最大声的一次。是的。我们当时，当史蒂夫在演那场情绪崩溃的戏时，他把手放在炉子上，拿起了那个东西，然后走到了外面。这东西是活动的吗？
So, you know, we were in the kitchen shooting Michael kind of having his breakdown, which is still possibly the, I think the hardest I think I've ever laughed on a set. Yes. We were, when, when Steven was having that thing where he's having the breakdown, he kind of puts his hand on the stove and picks up the thing and then goes outside. Is this supposed to come off?
他手里拿着它就走出来了。哦，天哪。我的意思是，那简直就是，那就是史蒂夫的天才之处。我，我当时真的以为我要笑死了，他每次拍一条都会做出不同的动作。我们在《晚餐聚会》（Dinner Party）里用了同一套公寓吗？我们设法保留了那个地方吗？
He walks out with it. Oh, God. I mean, that, that is like just, that's the genius of Steve. I, I, I literally thought I was going to die when he was doing it and every time we do a take, you do something different. Did we use that same condo in dinner party? Did we manage to keep that same place?
它看起来很眼熟。我对它眼熟极了。你们不觉得吗？就像厨房一样。我以为那就是那套公寓。Yeah。太神奇了。好吧，有趣的是，能够进去
It looked familiar. It looked very familiar to me. Didn't it to you? Like the kitchen. I thought it was the condo. Yeah. That's amazing. Well, what was, what was fun about that is being able to go
把它变成简（Jan）的家。Yeah。那就是，我的意思是，我不想，我不想，我不想剧透后面的剧集，但对于《晚餐聚会》来说，最有趣的部分就是：我们如何展现简的女性触感是如何融入其中的，比如墙上挂着和服。哦天哪，保罗，你一定要回来。你一定要来。
in and turn it into Jan's place. Yeah. And that's, that was, I mean, I don't want to, I don't want to, I don't want to jump episodes, but I mean, for dinner party, that was the most fun of like, how do we see how Jan's woman's touch went in with kimonos on the wall. Oh my gosh, Paul, you have to come back. You have to come in.
我们会聊得非常开心。我和迈克尔·舒尔聊过这一集。他是这一集的编剧，他跟我们分享了你在这一集中为史蒂夫拍摄时使用广角镜头的选择。你能稍微谈谈那个吗？Yeah。这就是，你知道的，我们真的希望他在这个场景中感到迷失，
We will have so much fun with that. I was talking to Mike sure about this episode. He was the writer of this episode and he shared with us your choice of using a wide angle lens when filming Steve for this episode. Can you talk a little bit about that? Yeah. It was just, you know, we really wanted him to feel lost in
在这个地方迷失，因为，你知道的，这很大程度上是关于他的不知所措。Yeah。我第一次遇到洛瑞——我妻子——的时候，也有过非常相似的经历，当时我们打算同居，你知道的，她找到了这个地方，我过去看，是以看房的名义去的。我只是打算去看看，了解一下
this, in this thing because, you know, it's so much about him being overwhelmed. Yeah. I had a very similar experience when I first met Lori, my wife, and we were going to move in together, you know, and she had found this place and I came over, it was under the guys. I was just going to like look at it and see what it was
它到底是怎样的。我万万没想到她其实已经把房产经纪人什么的都叫去了。而且就像，我得签字来拍板决定。所以突然之间，我从一个有点奇怪、孤独的单身汉，变成了要在所有人面前承诺搬进去。我当时有点吓坏了。
about. And little did I know she kind of had the realtor there and everything. And like, I had to sign the papers to pull the trigger. So suddenly I went from being like this kind of weird lonely bachelor to like committing to moving in in front of all these people. And I just kind of freaked out.
我只记得那种感觉，就好像突然之间房子变得非常抽象，就像你在拍恐怖片一样。你正在经历恐慌发作。所以我希望史蒂夫能有那种感觉，身处那栋房子里，就像是，你知道的，就像，我忘了有一部老电影，不是《迷魂记》（Obsession），但有些电影里女人在房子里发疯。
And I just remember that feeling of like suddenly the house felt very like abstract and like you're in a horror movie a little bit. You're having a panic attack. And so I wanted Steve to kind of feel that being, you know, in that house of like, it's almost like, you know, up, you know, I forget there's an old movie, not obsession, but something where this woman's going crazy in the house.
我只是觉得给它那种感觉会挺有趣的。哦天哪，我太喜欢这个故事了。洛瑞，真有你的，洛瑞。我跟你说，你看，我们马上要庆祝结婚25周年纪念日了。所以某种程度上它确实管用。好吧，我们还收到了很多关于酸奶盖的问题。
I just thought it'd be kind of funny to give it that feel. Oh my gosh, I love that story. Lori, you go Lori. I'm telling you, I know, look at that. You know, we would celebrate our 25 year anniversary, wedding anniversary. So it worked somehow. Well, we got a lot of questions also about the yogurt lids.
这可能是人们最好奇的东西，这些酸奶盖。哦天哪，大家对酸奶盖疯狂了，保罗。梅尔（Mel）想知道一共制作了多少枚奖牌。凯西（Casey）想知道，在最终选定酸奶盖之前，还有没有考虑过其他物品来做奖牌？你能给我们提供任何关于这些酸奶盖的信息。关于酸奶盖的任何事。
This was maybe the thing people are most curious about, these yogurt lids. Oh my gosh, they went crazy about the yogurt lids, Paul. Mel wanted to know how many medals were made. Casey wants to know, were any other items considered for medals before landing on yogurt lids? Literally any information you can give us about these yogurt lids. Anything about yogurt lids.
大家都很想知道。哇。因为我对此记忆犹新，就因为我记得当时觉得，这绝对不是我以为我们会用来做奖牌的东西。我记得菲尔——我记得菲尔·普罗斯（Phil Props）想出了那些点子。我还记得他是怎么用回形针做链子，然后把它挂在那里的。
People want to know. Wow. Cause I remember that so distinctly, just because I remember thinking it was, it was not at all what I thought we were going to make the medal. And I remember Phil, I remember Phil Props coming up with those. And I remember him rigging that up with, you know, with the paper clips of the chain and hanging of that out there.
我有那么一刻在想：我不知道它是否足够厚重，因为它们太轻了。但转念一想，这也是个绝妙的主意。所以我接受了这个。我有一些奇怪的记忆，我不知道准不准确，好像曾经考虑过干酪盖？哦，那个会更大。或者如果你喜欢更大的话。是的。
And I had moments of going like, I don't know if it's substantial enough because they're so light. But then thinking, but this was kind of brilliant too. And so going with this, I have some weird memory and I don't know if it's accurate or not of like a cottage cheese lids. Oh, it would be larger. Or for if you like and bigger. Yes.
但我想，我想我们可能觉得它们太大了，而且我觉得它们也挂不在回形针上。所以，但这只是一种模糊的记忆。史蒂夫·戈登（Steve Gordon）问了一个非常有趣的问题。在《怪胎与书呆子》里，哪个人能在办公室里工作？我觉得那一定得是林赛（Lindsay）。我觉得只有林赛能真正把事情搞定。并且能够恰当地应付那个老鼠般的房间。
But I think, I think we might have said they were too big and also I think they didn't stay on the, on the paper clip. So, but that, that's just a kind of a hazy memory. Steve Gordon asked, this is just kind of a fun question. Which one of the freaks and geeks could work in the office? I think it would have to be Lindsay. I think only Lindsay could really pull it together. And appropriately navigate that, that mouse room.
我懂你的意思。我觉得那是正确的选择。我觉得这是对的。然后，好吧，保罗，我们必须提一下，因为珍娜和我对你这一点喜爱有加，那就是你每天都穿着西装系着领带，而且我们的剧组在周五时也非常喜欢这样。在片场很多时候，剧组人员都会穿夏威夷衫。今天是周五嘛。
I hear that. I think that is the right choice. I think that is correct. And then, okay, Paul, we have to bring up because Jenna and I love this about you so much that you wear a suit every day with a tie and that our crew loved it so much on Friday. A lot of times on a set, the crew will wear Hawaiian shirts. It's Friday.
但每当你在的时候，他们在周五也都会系上领带。所以我们想知道，你每天穿西装的习惯起源于什么时候？那是《怪胎与书呆子》之后的事了，简单回顾一下。当我还是个孩子的时候，我总是穿着西装和领带。我很喜欢那样。大概从八岁左右就开始了。
But when you would work, they would all wear a tie on Friday. And, and so we were wondering when did your origin of the daily suit start? It was after freaks and geeks because flashed all the way back just briefly. When I was a kid, I used to wear suits and ties all the time. I loved that. That was kind of like starting like eight years old.
比如我让我妈妈给我买了我人生第一套三件套西装。然后我经常穿它。我爸爸当时气坏了，因为他说：“你六个月就会穿不下了。”他是对的。但是哦，穿着这些西装到处走的六个月，我过得可太棒了。所以这一直烙印在我的骨子里。但后来当我二十岁左右成为一名单口喜剧
Like I got my mom to buy me my first three piece suit. And then I wore it off. My dad was so mad because he's like, you're going to grow out of it in six months. And he was right. But oh, what a six months I had walking around with these suits. So it was always in me. But then when I got into my twenties and I became a standup
演员时，我以前，我以前在舞台上穿西装。然后我意识到我想要显得更，我不知道，更贴近观众。所以我开始穿牛仔奴和保龄球衫之类的衣服。然后当我拍《怪胎与书呆子》时，我，尽管我在高中时并不这样穿，但我开始只穿T恤和牛仔奴，因为我试图去揣摩
comedian, I used to, I used to wear a suit on stage. And then I realized I wanted to be more, I don't know, kind of relatable to the audience. So I started wearing like jeans and bowling shirts and that kind of thing. And then when I did freaks and geeks, I, I, even though I didn't dress this way in high school, I started dressing just like kind of T shirts and jeans because I was trying to get in the head of
喜剧演员，我以前，我以前在台上穿西装。然后我意识到我想变得更，我不知道，对观众来说更有亲和力。所以我开始穿牛仔裤、保龄球衫之类的那种衣服。然后当我拍《怪胎与书呆子》时，我，我，尽管我在高中时并不这样穿，但我开始只穿T恤和牛仔裤之类的，因为我想进入角色的内心
like the freaks and stuff. And so grew my hair really long. So you pictures of me from, from then my hair was super long, like down to my shoulder, I think. And, um, but then, so then it was after freaks and geeks was done and I was going out and pitching new shows and taking all these meetings that I was in these, in the meetings and there, all the executives would be in suits and ties.
就像《怪胎与书呆》那类剧。所以我的头发留得很长。所以你现在看我当时的那些照片，我的头发超级长，大概垂到肩膀。而且，嗯，不过后来，就在《怪胎与书呆》拍完之后，我出去推销新剧并开各种会，在那些会议上，所有的公司高管都穿着西装打着领带。
And I was there and like jeans and a T shirt. And I just didn't like it. I felt like really identifiable is sort of the, the prey, if you will, in that room. And so I remember going like, well, screw this, I'm going to go back to what I used to do and wear suits and ties. They kind of thought I was an idiot for doing it, but I just remember going like, I like the power structure of this better
而我坐在那儿，穿着牛仔裤和T恤。我就是不喜欢那样。我感觉自己真的很显眼，可以说是那个房间里的“猎物”一样。所以我记得当时想：“去他的，我要重操旧业，穿回西装系上领带。”他们觉得我这么做简直像个傻子，但我只记得当时想：“我更喜欢这种权力结构。”
of me in the suit like as an adult and just decided from that point on is like, I'm just going to wear a suit and tie all the time because I enjoy it and that makes me feel like an adult and also makes me feel in charge. And I, and I look better in a suit than I do in jeans. So there you go. Well, and Paul, without your suit, I wouldn't have my favorite hashtag you do, which is drunk funkel on your Instagram.
我作为一个成年人穿着西装的样貌，然后从那一刻起就决定：“我以后要一直穿着西装系领带”，因为我喜欢，这让我觉得自己像个成年人，也让我觉得自己掌控了一切。而且我穿西装比穿牛仔裤更好看。所以就这样吧。好吧，保尔，如果没有你的西装，我就不会有我最喜欢的标签了，也就是你在Instagram上的“酒鬼芬克尔”（drunk funkel）。
Thank you. I live for it. Paul, I love your Instagram so much. I want everyone to go follow Paul feet. And, and also Paul, I'm so excited about last Christmas. I am so excited to see it. I can't wait. And you know, I loved, I loved Game of Thrones.
谢谢你。我简直为它而活。保尔，我太喜欢你的Instagram了。我希望每个人都去关注保尔的脚。而且，保尔，我对《去年圣诞节》这部电影感到非常兴奋。我太想看了。我等不及了。你知道的，我超爱《权力的游戏》。
So of course Jenna doesn't watch Game of Thrones. It drives me crazy. So Amelia Clarkson. I'm still an Amelia Clark fan. Even though I didn't watch Game of Thrones. So this is very exciting to me because I get to see her and not Game of Thrones. Yes, exactly.
所以珍娜当然不看《权力的游戏》。这快把我逼疯了。所以艾米莉亚·克拉克。我仍然是艾米莉亚·克拉克的粉丝。尽管我没看《权力的游戏》。所以这对我来说非常令人兴奋，因为我能看到她，而不是《权力的游戏》。对，没错。
And then of course, like Emma Thompson, I cannot get enough of that woman. I just live for her. So, and, and Henry Golding and all of it. I can't wait to see it. I love, love holiday movies so much. So everybody go see last Christmas. Oh, yeah.
然后当然还有艾玛·汤普森，那个女人让我怎么看都看不够。我简直为她而活。所以，还有亨利·戈尔丁以及所有这些。我等不及要看了。我太喜欢、太喜欢节日电影了。所以大家快去看《去年圣诞节》。哦，对。
You'll love it. You'll laugh, you'll cry. And it's one of the most beautiful things I've ever shot. It's just absolutely gorgeous to look at. Oh, I can't wait. I cannot wait to see it. Paul, thank you so much for taking the time to do this. Thank you.
你会喜欢的。你会笑，你会哭。而且这是我拍过的最美的作品之一。画面绝对华丽极了。哦，我等不及了。我等不及要看了。保尔，非常感谢你抽出时间来做这件事。谢谢你。
Thank you, Paul. No, thank you. It's so much fun. I'm so glad you guys are doing this because the show is so special to me. I mean, honestly, I just, I have to pinch myself that I was got to be involved and be involved with so many episodes and so many kind of the bigger ones too.
谢谢你，保尔。不，谢谢你。这太有趣了。我很高兴你们在做这个，因为这部剧对我有特殊的意义。我是说，说实话，我简直得掐自己一下，才能相信我能参与其中，而且还参演了那么多集，其中也有很多非常重大的剧集。
And it will just always be one of my proudest, proudest moments and working with, with you guys with just, just one of my great joys. You were just such a wonderful cast to work with every, every day was really fun to come in and just every take was fun and different. And I mean, I just couldn't have had a better time. So thank you for that.
这将永远是我最自豪、最引以为傲的时刻之一，能和你们大家一起合作简直是我最大的快乐之一。你们真的是一个非常棒的演员阵容，每天来片场都超级开心，每一次拍摄都充满乐趣而且风格各异。我是说，我不可能有过比这更好的时光了。所以为此谢谢你们。
And I love you guys very, very much. Oh, Paul. Thank you, Paul. Okay, guys, we're back and now we are going to break down Office Olympics. Yeah. That was so nice talking to Paul. That was so great.
我非常非常爱你们。哦，保尔。谢谢你，保尔。好了，各位，我们回来了，现在我们要来剖析《办公室奥运会》。对。和保尔聊天太棒了。真的太棒了。
All right. Let's get into this episode scene by scene. We start with Michael's talking head. He explains that he has come in early and we learned that Ryan had to come in early to bring Michael a sausage, egg and cheese biscuit. Ryan is so pissed. Angela, I noticed a little bit of Ryan sass.
好了。让我们一幕一幕地切入这一集。我们从迈克尔的单人采访开始。他解释说他来得很早，然后我们得知瑞安不得不早起，给迈克尔买一个香肠鸡蛋芝士饼。瑞安气坏了。安吉拉，我注意到了一点瑞安的傲慢。
Yeah, Ryan had some sass. Can I get Ryan sass from you? Yeah. Do you have a card that says Ryan sass? I don't because the only person that bumps me with sass is Pam. I knew, I knew it was targeted. I knew your sass was not universal. I knew it was personal.
对，瑞安确实有点傲慢。你能对我展现一下瑞安式的傲慢吗？行。你有一张写着“瑞安式傲慢”的卡片吗？我没有，因为唯一让我觉得被冒犯到傲慢的人是帕姆。我知道，我知道这是有针对性的。我知道你的傲慢不是针对所有人的。我知道这是针对个人的。
See, I just proved it. I also remember that Steve had to eat all of those egg and cheese biscuits and he had a bucket under his desk because he would spit them out because remember, he had just gotten in this amazing shape. And I feel like season one Steve might have enjoyed eating all of those, but season two Steve was like, I'm not doing that to my body anymore.
看，我刚刚证明了这一点。我还记得史蒂夫不得不吃掉所有那些鸡蛋芝士饼，他的书桌底下放着一个桶，因为他要把它们吐出来，因为你们记得，他当时已经练出了极好的身材。我觉得第一季的史蒂夫可能会很享受吃所有这些东西，但第二季的史蒂夫会觉得：我再也不这样折磨我的身体了。
Also though, I mean, listen, here's the thing. When you have to eat that much food, like the same food over and over, maybe 30 takes of that food, it turns on you. It does. You don't need that sausage egg biscuit turning on you. It's true. I'd spit it out.
不过话又说回来，我是说，听着，情况是这样的。当你不得不吃那么多食物，比如反复吃同样的食物，可能要拍30条这样的食物，它就会开始反胃。确实会的。你可不需要那个香肠鸡蛋饼让你反胃。真的。我会把它吐出来。
All right. So then there's another scene that has the thing that I love so much, which is when we start on Michael speaking to camera and we widened to reveal Dwight lurking over his shoulder. It is one of your favorite, favorite talking heads. And this is when Michael reveals he is buying a condo going to become a homeowner.
好的。接下来还有另一个场景，有着我非常喜欢的东西，那就是我们开始时是迈克尔对着镜头说话，然后镜头拉宽，露出德怀特在他肩膀后面窥视。这是你们最最喜欢的单人采访之一。正是在这里，迈克尔透露他要买一套公寓，要成为房主了。
Yeah, big day for him. And then we swoop into the main office. And did you notice this, Angela? The photo on Jim's desk. I have two note cards about these opening shots in the bullpen at a minute 48 seconds. Do you know what Jim's screensaver is? What?
对，对他来说是个大日子。然后我们切入主办公室。安吉拉，你注意到这个了吗？吉姆桌子上的照片。关于一分四十八秒时开放式办公区的这些开场镜头，我有两张便签。你知道吉姆的屏保是什么吗？什么？
It's a deserted island in the middle of the ocean. I think that's a little foreshadowing to the fire. Which is coming next. Coming next, that desert island. At a minute 51, John's desk right next to his computer. There's a photo of him holding a baby. Do you know who that is? It's his nephew.
那是大海中间的一座荒岛。我觉得这有点在暗示火灾。火灾接下来就要发生了。接下来就要发生，那座荒岛。在一分五十一秒时，约翰的桌子紧挨着他的电脑。有一张他抱着一个婴儿的照片。你知道那是谁吗？那是他的侄子。
It's his nephew. So when we had to personalize our desk, that's one of the things John brought in. He was so proud to be an uncle. I know. He's adorable. He was so excited to put that picture on his desk. Then we go to the scene where Jim and Pam are throwing things
那是他的侄子。所以当我们必须个性化我们的办公桌时，那是约翰带来的东西之一。他为能成为一个叔叔而感到骄傲。我知道。他太可爱了。他非常兴奋地把那张照片放在他的桌子上。然后我们来到吉姆和帕姆扔东西的场景。
into Dwight's cup. This is when Pam has to revive Jim because sometimes he dies of boredom. I remember shooting that. That was really fun. John and I got really into seeing if we really could throw stuff in the cup. Like sometimes that happens where it's in the scene, but then
扔进德怀特的杯子里。正是在这个时候，帕姆不得不“复苏”吉姆，因为有时他会无聊得快要死掉。我记得拍摄那个场景的情景。真的超级好玩。我和约翰真的很热衷于看看我们是不是真的能把东西扔进杯子里。就像有时会发生这种情况，它在剧情里，但接着
in real life you actually really enjoy it. That was a moment. Well, I have a little something from that scene. At two minutes, four seconds, boom. The boom drops in the scene. The boom operator. Yeah, we got a little bit of boom and they left it in because as you know, it was a mockumentary.
在现实生活中你其实真的乐在其中。那真是一个时刻。好吧，我从那个场景里拿了一点小东西。在两分钟零四秒时，轰的一声。吊杆话筒掉进了镜头里。收音师。对，我们穿帮了一点收音师的设备，他们把它留下了，因为如你们所知，这是一个伪纪录片。
So when that happened, they let it stay. They wouldn't let it ruin a take. But there's a boom in that scene. What about Dwight's Mozart, Butch Cassidy talking head? This to me is such a sign of Mike Scherr's writing. I think if you go back and look at every amazing Dwight talking head, most of them were written by Mike Scherr. Mike is brilliant.
所以当这种情况发生时，他们让它留着。他们不会让它毁掉一个镜头。但那个场景里确实穿帮了一个吊杆话筒。那德怀特关于莫扎特和布奇·卡西迪的单人采访呢？对我来说，这绝对是迈克·舒尔编剧风格的标志。我觉得如果你回过头去看每一个精彩的德怀特单人采访，其中大部分都是迈克·舒尔写的。迈克太才华横溢了。
He is brilliant and he's smart. And I mean, I feel like I would wear a t-shirt that says Mozart and Butch Cassidy. You're going to get a bullet in your head thanks to Butch Cassidy if you mess with Mozart, everybody. I'm not messing with Mozart. No. Again, Michael's list of magazines.
他才华横溢而且很聪明。我是说，我觉得我会穿一件印有“莫扎特和布奇·卡西迪”字样的T恤。如果你敢跟莫扎特过不去，大家注意了，由于布奇·卡西迪的关系，你的脑袋里会挨一颗子弹。我才没有跟莫扎特过不去。没有。再说迈克尔的杂志清单。
He lists off all his magazines. He asked Pam if she has forwarded, cracked, and American Way magazine to his new condo. I just want to point that out. His magazines are Small Businessman, Maxim, American Way, Cracked, and then the Fine Arts, Efficient Nado. Yeah, the one he made up. Yeah, the fake magazine.
他列出了他的所有杂志。他问帕姆有没有把《Small Businessman》、《Maxim》、《American Way》、《Cracked》这几本杂志以及《Fine Arts Efficient Nado》转发到他的新公寓去。我只想指出这一点。他的杂志有《Small Businessman》、《Maxim》、《American Way》、《Cracked》，还有艺术类的《Efficient Nado》。对，他自己瞎编的那本。对，假杂志。
We also get to see Michael's car in this episode for the first time. Is it for the first time? I think it is. Well, I have a pretty big note card before we get to the seabring. Oh, well, then go ahead. At what minutes is the seabring?
我们在这一集中也是第一次看到迈克尔的车。这是第一次吗？我想是的。好吧，在我们看到赛百灵之前，我有一张非常大的便签。哦，那你就说吧。赛百灵出现在第几分钟？
Don't know. I don't write down minutes. That's your thing. It's weird. I like a good list, but you're really obsessed with these minutes. You know what? You and your clins can suck it, Fisher.
不知道。我不记分钟数。那是你的专长。这很奇怪。我喜欢列好清单，但你真的对这些分钟数着迷。你知道吗？你和你的那些清洁排毒法见鬼去吧，费舍尔。
All right. My background people who love background stuff. At four minutes, 52 seconds, Jim is talking to Oscar and Oscar's desk faces the partition that is between Angela and Kevin. Okay. And on that partition is a post-it note. It's a drawing that Oscar drew.
好吧。我的背景迷们，那些喜欢背景细节的人。在四分钟五十二秒时，吉姆正在和奥斯卡说话，奥斯卡的办公桌正对着安吉拉和凯文之间的隔板。好吧。而在那个隔板上有一张便利贴。那是奥斯卡画的一幅画。
And after this episode, he gave it to me and I still have it. And I, so here's the thing. What is it? Okay. So Oscar is a very good drawer. He's very good and he would make these doodles and I kept a lot of them and he often would draw Kevin, Angela and Oscar, our characters doing crazy things.
在这集之后，他把它送给了我，我到现在还留着。所以，事情是这样的。那是什么？好吧。所以奥斯卡是个非常优秀的画师。他非常棒，他会画这些涂鸦，我保留了其中很多张，而且他经常会画凯文、安吉拉和奥斯卡，也就是我们这些角色做一些疯狂的事情。
I have a drawing one of one where we're on a moped. Oh, I've seen that one. That's so cute. Okay. So this post-it note is a drawing he did is one of my personal favorites. It is Angela as a dominatrix. She is getting a shoulder ride from Kevin.
我有一张画，上面画着我们骑着轻便摩托车。哦，我见过那张。太可爱了。好吧。所以这张便利贴是他画的一幅画，是我个人最喜欢的一幅。那是安吉拉扮演施虐女王。她正骑在凯文的肩膀上。
Okay. She has a whip in her hand like she's cracking the whip. And on all fours being drugged behind them is Oscar by Elish. Wow. Yes. That is what's on the post-it note on his partition. And it cracks me up.
好吧。她手里拿着一根鞭子，做出挥鞭的动作。而在他们身后被四肢着地拖着走的是奥斯卡·内利什。哇。是的。这就是贴在他隔板上的便利贴上的内容。这让我笑得停不下来。
Like the detail that he drew our costumes are dominatrix costumes. He has like a spike color on. He definitely would do all these drawings of the accounting department and my character was always invoking pain in some way. But it is one of my favorite things I own is this post-it note that he drew and it's there on the partition at
就像他画的细节一样，我们的服装是施虐女王的服装。他戴着一个带尖刺的项圈。他绝对会画所有这些关于会计部门的画，而我的角色总是在某种程度上带来痛苦。但这是我拥有的最喜欢的东西之一，就是他画的这张便利贴，它就贴在四分钟五十二秒时的隔板上。
four minutes, 52 seconds. I about fell off my couch. I was so excited. But then after that, he gave it to you after this episode and we, you would never see it again on the show. It just lived there for this episode. It lived there.
我差点从沙发上摔下来。我太兴奋了。但在这之后，在这集之后他把它给了你，然后我们，你在剧里就再也看不到了。它只在这集里出现过。它就贴在那里。
He drew it clearly that day and stuck it up there. Yeah. And I now have it. Oh, I love that. And then also at four minutes, 52 seconds because we were allowed to personalize our desks, right? There is a photo that Oscar brought in of himself and his dog in a frame.
他显然是那天画的，然后贴上去的。对。而我现在拥有它。哦，我太喜欢了。然后还有在四分钟五十二秒，因为我们被允许个性化我们的办公桌，对吧？有一张奥斯卡带来的他自己和他的狗在一个相框里的照片。
Oh. Yeah. So there you go. I want to talk a little bit about Michael's car. Okay. He has the Sebring convertible. I think this is the first time we really see the car. It's certainly the first time we drive in the car.
哦。对。所以就是这样。我想多聊聊迈克尔的车。好吧。他开着赛百灵敞篷车。我觉得这是我们第一次真正看到这辆车。这绝对是我们第一次开这辆车。
It is. The first time it's featured. And BJ told me that they picked this car very carefully. They felt like it was the flashiest car Michael could afford on his salary. It's a convertible. Yes.
是的。第一次出镜。BJ告诉我，他们非常小心地选了这辆车。他们觉得这是迈克尔凭他的薪水能买得起的最高调的车。这是一辆敞篷车。是的。
He's very, very proud of it. And when Michael and Dwight leave the office and they're shooting that scene, Randall Einhorn, our director of photography and also our main camera operator was shoved in the backseat in order to get those shots. Randall is a big guy and that is not a big backseat. No.
他对此感到非常非常骄傲。当迈克尔和德怀特离开办公室并拍摄那个场景时，兰德尔·艾恩霍恩，我们的摄影指导兼主要摄像师，为了拍那些镜头被塞进了后座。兰德尔是个大个子，而那并不是一个很大的后座。没有。
He told me that his knees were up by his ears. He was contorted in this weird position. I traded some messages with him and he said though that whenever they had to get in the most painful position, they usually got the best shot. So he was like, you knew you were getting a great shot if you were hurting. And I also, the back window of the seabring broke in
他告诉我，他的膝盖都快顶到耳朵了。他以这种奇怪的姿势扭曲着。我和他互发了一些消息，他说每当他们不得不摆出最痛苦的姿势时，他们通常能拍到最好的镜头。所以他的意思是：如果你觉得疼，你就知道你拍到一个绝佳的镜头了。而且我还要说，赛百灵的后车窗在这一集里碎了，而兰德尔在网因上为此背了锅。
this episode and Randall has been blamed for this on the internet. Really? Yes. The internet says that Randall broke the window and it had to be replaced. It cost almost $900 to replace. I know because, you know, we rented these cars, we
真的吗？是的。网因上说兰德尔打破了车窗，不得不进行更换。更换费用将近900美元。我知道，因为，你知道的，我们是租这些车的，我们没有买。
didn't buy them. I asked Randall about it and he said actually the window did break. He said, this I thought was interesting, he said he thinks it's because they left a camera battery pack on the back shelf and then when they put the convertible top down, it crunched. But who's they, Randall?
我问过兰德尔这件事，他说其实车窗确实碎了。他说，我觉得这很有意思，他说他觉得这是因为他们把一个摄像机电池组落在了后搁板上，然后当他们把敞篷车顶放下来时，它就被挤碎了。但“他们”是谁，兰德尔？
Who is they? Would that be film crew? Would that be you? Camera? So he said they, but yes, it did break in that scene and we had to then replace it. Okay. So I have a little story about the seabring.
“他们”是谁？那是电影摄制组吗？那是你吗？摄影组？所以他说“他们”，但是是的，那个场景里车窗确实碎了，我们随后不得不更换它。好吧。所以我有一个关于赛百灵的小故事。
I have a time code. Now we're jumping ahead, but since you're talking about it, I'm going to bring it up, Jenna. Is that all right? I'll allow it. Oh Lord. At 16 minutes 39 seconds, there is proof of what the actual outside temperature was because there is a
我有一个时间码。现在我们要跳过一点，但既然你在谈论它，我就把它提出来，珍娜。这可以吗？我允许了。哦天哪。在十六分钟三十九秒时，有证据证明当时的实际室外温度是多少，因为镜头里有一个对赛百灵仪表盘的特写。上面显示他们正朝东行驶，气温是91华氏度。
full on camera shot of the dashboard in the seabring. It says that they are going east and that it is 91 degrees. Yes. Because we shot this in the middle of summer. In the middle of summer, we had to have coats on and pretend to be cold, but there you have it. It was 91 degrees.
是的。因为我们在盛夏拍摄这个。在盛夏，我们得穿着大衣，假装很冷，但事实就是如此。当时是91度。好吧，安吉拉，我有一个关于“恨球”（hate ball）的问题。哦，我有一张关于“恨球”的便签。好吧。你的头发。是的。在“恨球”里。是的。
Okay. Angela, I have a question about hate ball. Oh, I have a note card about hate ball. All right. Your hair. Yes. In hate ball. Yes.
你的，能请你谈谈那个编发发带的东西吗？我一直想说来着。好吧。所以在五分钟四十二秒时，通过隔板能看到我的一张很棒的镜头，因为很显然我讨厌他们在做的事。所以他们喊出“恨球”，然后镜头切到我，我在皱眉。
Your, will you please talk about the braid headband thing? I have been wanting to. Okay. So at five minutes 42 seconds, there is a great shot of me through the partition because obviously I hate what they're doing. So they say hate ball and they cut to me and I'm
你看到了经典的头带编发，那是我们的发型师金·费里（Kim Ferry）设计的。她在剧里每天都给我弄头发。她其实是一个非常厉害的编发师。她会做任何种类的编发，安吉拉·马丁所有的那些复杂编发和发型都是出自金·费里之手。
frowning. You see the classic headband braid that was created by our hairdresser, Kim Ferry. She did my hair every day on the show. She actually is an amazing braider. She can do any kind of braid and all of my intricate braids and hairstyles of Angela Martin were by Kim Ferry.
所以她把这个叫做“头带编发”，她让我做的是把我的头发用夹板拉直。好吧。她让我把头倒过来，然后从我的一侧耳朵开始，在头顶上方做一个这种反向编发，一直编到另一侧耳朵结束，让脑后的头发保持直顺。所以它基本上只编一圈，就像一个横跨头顶的头带一样。这会疼吗？
So she called this the headband braid and what she would have me do is she would flat iron my hair straight. Okay. She would have me flip my head over and then she would start at one side of my ear and do this like inverted braid over the top of my head ending at the other side of my ear, leaving the back of
一点也不疼，但我确实得让我的头部保持一种有点扭曲的姿势。为了弄出这个发型。为了弄好它。但这绝对是我们最喜欢的东西之一。格雷格·丹尼尔斯超级喜欢。他第一次看到它时，就说：“哦天哪。是的。是的。这就是安吉拉·马丁。”
my hair straight. So it would only braid like basically like a headband that went over like the top of my head. Did it hurt? It did not hurt, but I did have to sit with my head kind of contorted. In order to get the style. In order to get it.
并且它后来在很多集里都有出现。我们甚至为NBC.com制作了一个幕后花絮，因为有太多人问那是不是我真正的头发。那就是我真正的头发，把头倒过来做反向编发，让它看起来像一个发带。那个头带编发一点也不疼。比起盘发，你远会更喜欢这个。
But it was like one of our favorite things. Greg Daniels loved it. The first time he saw it, he was like, oh my God. Yes. Yes. This is Angela Martin. And it went on to be featured in a lot of episodes. We even did a behind the scenes for NBC.com because
对。是的。这就像是把一部分头发编起来，但它并不紧，也没有拉扯我后脑勺的头发。对我来说，这才是经典的安吉拉。对，头带编发。是的。说到头发。是的。在六分钟十五秒时，你走到办公室后面，因为他们在玩“邓德球”（dunderball）。
so many people asked if that was my real hair. It was my real hair flipped upside down inverted braid and it made it look like a headband. The headband braid did not hurt. Like you would far prefer this over a bun. Yes. Yeah. It's just like having a part of your hair braided,
是的。然后你看到凯利仍然梳着盘发。凯利依然是盘发。但稍微松了一点。后面好像有一小缕头发垂下来。就像是一个松散的辫子。它开始散下来了，珍娜。你知道吗？
but it wasn't tight or pulling at the back of my head. To me, that is classic Angela. Yeah, the headband braid. Yes. Speaking of hair. Yes. At six minutes, 15 seconds, you go in the back of the office because they're playing dunderball.
我想，而且我来预测一下，因为我们还没看完全部剧集。我们真的是按顺序在看的。我觉得她的头发在《赌场之夜》里会散下来。我觉得那是她的头发第一次散下来。我要预测一下。所以让我们看看我猜得对不对。让我们看看你猜得对不对。
Yes. And you see that Kelly still has an updo. Still an updo with Kelly. But it's a little bit looser. There's like a little piece kind of dangling in the back. It's like a loose braid. It's starting to come down, Jenna. You know what?
随着我们继续重看。因为我知道她的头发在《赌场之夜》里是散着的。好吧，我记得。发髻越来越松了。我们正在朝那个方向前进，各位。很有意思。她的头发散下来的时机，正是吉姆和帕姆越来越接近接吻的时候。差不多吧。
I think, and I'm going to predict because we have not watched all the episodes. We really are watching them in order. I think her hair comes down in Casino Night. I think it's the first time her hair comes down. I'm going to predict it. So let's see if I'm right. Let's see if you're right.
我不知道。什么？那根本毫无逻辑。你知道吗？你知道那个相关性是什么吗？什么？排毒关联。哦，不。
As we continue to rewatch. Because I know her hair is down in Casino Night. Well, I remember. The bun is getting looser. We're heading there, folks. It's interesting. It's her hair comes down the closer Jim and Pam get to kissing. Sort of.
那是你们的排毒逻辑。那是排毒逻辑。我们来聊聊迈克尔的公寓吧，拜托。好的。他到了他的公寓。正如我们在“快速事实”里所说的那样，房地产经纪人由南希·卡瑞尔饰演。所以我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones）
I don't know. What? That just makes no sense. You know what? You know what that correlation is? What? A cleanse correlation. Oh, no.
向剧组推荐了南希来演这个角色。她觉得南希完美契合。我给艾莉森发了邮件，她说她一直是南希的超级粉丝。从我们剧开拍的第一天起，她就一直在为她找一个合适的位置。她觉得这简直完美。她很喜欢能让南希和史蒂夫
That's cleanse logic for you guys. That's cleanse logic. Let us talk about Michael's condo, please. Yes. He gets to his condo. And like we said in our Fast Facts, the realtor is played by Nancy Carell. So our casting director, Allison Jones,
以这种方式针锋相对。迈克·舒尔告诉我，当南希在片场时，史蒂夫高兴得整个人有点飘飘然。他总是咯咯笑着，感到非常开心，因为他们俩在一起太可爱了。而且我们都知道他们在一起太可爱了。是的。她超级搞笑而且非常聪明。但史蒂夫，如果你想遇到一个像史蒂夫爱南希那样爱你的男人。
pitched Nancy for this role. She thought Nancy would be perfect. I emailed with Allison and she said that she had always been a huge fan of Nancy's. And she was looking from day one on our show to find a place for her. And she thought this was perfect. She loved being able to pit Nancy and Steve
那绝对是的。因为他完全被她逗乐了。我喜欢迈克尔开始失控的时候，因为他意识到，你知道的，而且德怀特还在火上浇油。德怀特说：“你知道的，你七十多岁的时候就会死。你基本上是在买一口棺材。”是的。
against one another in this way. Mike sure told me that Steve was positively giddy when Nancy was on set. He was just giggly and delighted that they're so cute together. And we know they're so cute together. Yeah. She is hilarious and so smart. But Steve, you want to meet a man that loves you
如果我要买棺材，我会买一个听不见其他死人声音的棺材。但迈克尔在情绪失控时，有句台词我非常喜欢，他说：“说好这里有很多辣妹的呢？辣妹在哪儿？”就像什么，在这个公寓开发区里，承诺过会有辣妹。但南希对此的反应才是真正的精髓所在。
the way Steve loves Nancy. For sure. Because he's just delighted by her. I love when Michael starts to spiral out because he realizes, you know, and Dwight is not helping. Dwight's like, you know, you're going to be 75. You're basically buying a coffin. Yeah.
安吉拉，你有一张关于公寓的三星卡片。好吧，是在六分钟五十八秒时。与其说是关于公寓，不如说是我们在公寓里发现的信息，那就是德怀特拥有一个六十英亩的甜菜农场。是的。这是第一次提到他的甜菜农场。是的。
If I bought a coffin, I'd buy one where I couldn't hear the other dead people. But Michael, as he's spiraling, has this line that I love where he's like, I was promised hot people. Where are the hot people? Like what, in this condo development, you were promised hot people. But Nancy's reaction to that is really what makes it.
而且你提到了我们看到了摩斯的照片。但正是在这里我们得知德怀特是个地主。他有一个运作中的甜菜农场。是的。这就引发了一个粉丝的问题，安吉拉。斯坦写道：在这一集中，德怀特说他的父母给他留了一个六十英亩的甜菜农场。但在第九季的农场里，莎莉阿姨把农场
Angela, you have a three star card about the condo. Well, it's at six minutes, 58 seconds. It's not so much about the condo, but it's what information we find out at the condo, which is that Dwight has a 60 acre beet farm. Yes. This is the first mention of his beet farm. Yes.
留给了所有三个孩子，前提是他们搬回里面住。珍娜，这个出入是因为你偷了剧本圣经吗？斯坦，剧本圣经就在我这里。我正在翻看剧本圣经的第31页。上面写着，在《办公室奥运会》里，德怀特说他拥有一个由他祖父留给他的六十英亩运作中的甜菜农场。而且，斯坦，如果你想看六分钟五十八秒，
And you mentioned that we see a photo of Moe's. But this is when we learned that Dwight is a landowner. He has a working beet farm. Yes. And this brings up a fan question, Angela. Stan wrote, in this episode, Dwight says that his parents left him a 60 acre beet farm. But in the farm in season nine, Aunt Sally leaves the farm
德怀特对着镜头做了一个单人采访，他说：“我的祖父母留给我一个六十英亩的甜菜农场。”是的。所以，斯坦，我必须说这确实还是引发了一个问题：为什么在第九季里我们会说是他的莎莉阿姨拥有那个甜菜农场？我不知道。我需要重新看一遍第九季，因为我知道有一个雪莉阿姨
to all three kids if they move back into it. Jenna, did this discrepancy happen because you stole the show Bible? Stan, I have the show Bible right here. I'm referring to page 31 of the show Bible. And it says that in office Olympics, Dwight says he has a 60 acre working beet farm left to him by his grandfather. And also, Stan, if you want to go to six minutes 58 seconds,
因为她扇了我一巴掌，还骂我是厨房女巫。对。但我不知道莎莉阿姨是谁。好吧，他有很多亲戚。哦，我知道。各位，我真的想说，为了在剧本圣经里找到这个出处，我差不多读了关于德怀特·舒尔的五页纸的事实。
Dwight has a talking head to camera where he says, my grandparents left me a 60 acre beet farm. Yes. So, Stan, I do have to say this still does bring up the question of why in season nine do we say that it's his Aunt Sally who has the beet farm? I don't know. I need to revisit season nine because I know an Aunt Shirley
我觉得如果他们把剧本圣经里德怀特·舒尔的那部分单独出版，一定会卖得非常好。这里的每一个要点都是黄金。随便挑一个随机的读给我们听听吧。好的。来自剧本圣经，这一章是关于德怀特的。认为狼对办公室职员构成重大威胁。认为狼构成重大威胁。
because she slapped me and called me a kitchen witch. Yeah. But I don't know who Aunt Sally is. Well, he has a number of relatives. Oh, I know. You guys, I do want to say that to find this reference in the show Bible, I had to read something like five pages of facts about Dwight Shrut.
对。第三季第二十集，他说他有一个防空洞。花了他1200美元。他自己给自己做了割礼。不。不。他打喷嚏时可以睁着眼睛。这些太惊人了。
And I think that if they only published the Dwight Shrut section of the show Bible, it would do very well. Every single one of these bullet points is gold. Just pick one random one and read it to us. All right. From the show Bible, the chapter is Dwight. Thanks wolves are a major threat to office workers. Thanks wolves are a major threat.
他认为三角龙是最逊的恐龙。我有点想让你把它。我是说，我可以一直读下去。对。用鹿鞭作为春药。哦天哪，可怜的安吉拉·马丁。似乎是个摔跤迷。不仅仅是为了表面装装样子。这个把我逗得哈哈大笑。
Yeah. Season three, episode 20, he says that he has a bomb shelter. It cost him $1,200. He performed his own circumcision. No. No. He can sneeze with his eyes open. These are amazing.
他的农场是非有机的。他使用杀虫剂吗？我猜是的。在某集里，他一定吹嘘过他的农场是非有机的。他有三万美元埋得很深，而且埋在某个人下面，他不想为了挖出它们而把那个人挖出来。各位，我是说，我真的。关于德怀特的。
He thinks triceratops is the lamest dinosaur. I kind of want you to make it. I mean, I could go on and on. Yeah. Uses deer penis as an aphrodisiac. Oh God, poor Angela Martin. Appears to be a fan of wrestling. Just fakes it.
他们完全可以做整整一集，让我只给你们读剧本圣经里的德怀特·舒尔。这太神奇了。不过是的，六分钟五十八秒。重磅信息，那就是德怀特拥有一个六十英亩的甜菜农场。这是他们为我们剧中的一个角色想出的最棒的点子之一，因为我们将永远从这个事实中挖掘源源不断的金矿。永远。
Not just for appearances. This one made me laugh out loud. His farm is non-organic. He uses pesticides? I guess so. In some episode, he must brag about the fact that his farm is non-organic. He has $30,000 buried very deeply and under someone, and he
我这里有一张八分三十六秒的小卡片。那是开幕式。是的。有一条横幅。还有点燃火炬。我想跟你们分享一个小小的幕后故事。所以每当有点燃的蜡烛时，我们按法律规定必须开一次安全会议。是的。
doesn't want to dig past them to get it. Guys, I mean, I really. The Dwight. They could do a whole episode where I just read you Dwight Shrut from the show Bible. That is amazing. But yeah, six minutes, 58 seconds. Huge information, which is that Dwight owns a 60 acre
我过去常常笑死，因为我会想到那些有飞车追逐和爆炸之类场面的剧集。而我们的剧里，你要为点燃一支蜡烛开安全会议。我们的第二副导演凯莉·坎特利（Kelly Cantley）会说：“安全会议。我们将点燃一支蜡烛。
beet farm. This is one of my favorite things that they came up with for a character on our show because we are just going to continue to mine gold from this fact forever. Forever. I have a little card here at eight minutes, 36 seconds. There are the opening ceremonies. Yes.
是的。那是真正的火，片场的所有人。请注意你们在蜡烛附近的衣袖和手肘。一支点燃的蜡烛，各位。好了。安全会议到此结束。”这很有趣，因为我后来去拍一些剧或项目时，我们会开安全会议，他们会带着那种同样的虚张声势宣布，但他们
There's a banner. There's the lighting of a candle. I wanted to share a little behind the scenes story for you guys. So whenever we had a lit candle, we had to by law have a safety meeting. Yeah. And I used to crack up because I would think about shows
实际上会说：“所有人注意。两点钟会有一辆车发生爆炸。是的。所以请保持距离。车爆炸后请不要靠近它，因为它会很烫。”但在我们的剧里，我们将有一支蜡烛。它将用打火机点燃。
that had car chases and explosives and things. And on our show, you had a safety meeting about a candle being lit. And our second AD, Kelly Cantley would go safety meeting. We will have a lit candle. Yes. That is real fire, everyone on the set.
而且还是一个非常长的打火机。一个非常长的打火机，为了保护约翰的手。安全会议。我想说，在开幕式的同一个场景里，那个写着“第一届邓德米夫林奥林匹克运动会”的牌子真的是我画的。那个牌子是你画的？我画的。
Please be aware of your sleeves and elbows around the candle. A lit candle, everyone. Okay. Safety meeting adjourned. And it's funny because I would go on to do shows or projects where we would have safety meetings and they would be said with sort of that same bravado, but they
你给它上色了吗？是的。那个牌子是你做的。是的。怎么搞的，真的吗？是我做的。那些是我的泡泡字体。是我画的。
would really be like, everyone pay attention. A car will be exploding at two o'clock. Yeah. So please keep your distance. Do not go toward the car after it has exploded as it will be hot. But on our show, we will have one candle. It will be lit with a lighter.
我还拼装了很多酸奶盖的东西。你这是作为体验派表演的一部分吗？不，这不是我的体验派表演的一部分。他们给了我一些回形针和酸奶盖，拍了一些我在桌上拼奖牌的镜头。我们从来没用过，但我确实做了。然后那个牌子也是我自己做的。
A very long lighter too. A very long lighter to protect John's hands. Safety meeting. I want to say in that same scene with the opening ceremonies, I really drew the sign that says games of the first Thunder Mifflin Olympiad. You drew that? I drew it.
那他们当时希望你做那个牌子吗？我不记得了。还是说你出于体验派表演的本能自告奋勇？你知道的，我觉得菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）走到我面前说：“你想做这个牌子吗，既然是帕姆做的？”我说：“当然。为什么不呢？”有时候他们会问我，你知道的，
Did you color it in? Yes. You made the sign. Yes. What the hell, really? I made it. Those are my bubble letters. I drew it.
“安吉拉，你的角色要递出这张纸。你想把所有内容都手写出来，这样就是你的字迹吗？”我们总是这样做。我们总是会做那种细节。我很喜欢那个细节。嗯-hmm。继续我们关于办公室奥运会的对话，
I also put together a lot of the yogurt lid things. I did it as part of your method acting. No, it's not part of my method acting. They gave me some paper clips and yogurt lids, and they had some shots of me putting together the medals at my desk. We never used it, but I did do it. And then I also made that sign myself.
我们应该聊聊“飞盘投掷”（Flunkerton）这个游戏。是的，我们应该。我收到了很多问题。人们问，“飞盘投掷”是剧本写好的还是即兴发挥的？这是一句写在剧本里的台词，但导演让我表现得好像是我当场即兴瞎编的一样。是的，那是剧本写好的。很多人还问是谁想出了“飞盘投掷”这个词。
Now, did they want you to make that sign? I don't remember. Or did you volunteer in your method acting ways? You know, I feel like Phil Shea came up to me and said, do you want to make the sign since Pam made it? And I said, sure. Why not? There were times where they would ask me, you know,
是迈克·舒尔。好吧，迈克说要么是他要么是格雷格·丹尼尔斯，但他本人对“FL”这个发音着迷，“FL”。对。那个“FL”的发音。他觉得这非常搞笑。他说这也是托比的姓氏的由来，迈克对此负有责任。
Angela, your character is going to hand this piece of paper. Do you want to write out all the things so it's in your handwriting? And we always did. We always would sort of do that kind of thing. I liked that detail. Mm-hmm. Continuing our conversation about the office Olympics,
所以他很确信自己可以宣称写出了“飞盘投掷”。我记得菲莉丝拍那个场景时玩得超级开心。她玩得太高兴了。菲莉丝很喜欢打篮球、玩“飞盘投掷”。玩游戏。她想成为参与者。她确实想。她非常兴奋。
we should talk about the game Flunkerton. Yes, we should. I got a lot of questions. People asked, was Flunkerton scripted or improved? It was a written line, but I was told to deliver it like I was making it up on the spot. Yes, that was scripted. A lot of people also asked who came up with the term Flunkerton.
我觉得，珍娜，我这里有两张便签，我觉得我们应该把这些游戏稍微梳理一下。我们来吧。好的。首先，是人们玩的不属于办公室奥运会、但构成了吉姆灵感的那些游戏。是的。
It was Mike Scherr. Well, Mike said it was either him or Greg Daniels, but he is personally obsessed with the FL sound, the FL. Yeah. The FL sound. He thinks it's very funny. He said that is also how Toby got his last name, that Mike was responsible for that.
当他走到每个人的办公桌区域时。所以帕姆当然是把东西（扔进德怀特的咖啡杯里）。会计部有“恨球”。人力资源部有“邓德球”。斯坦利说他努力工作是为了让他的孩子们能上大学。然后安吉拉·马丁说她玩的是“帕姆乒乓”（Pampong）。
So he's pretty sure he can claim having written Flunkerton. I remember Phyllis had so much fun doing that scene. She had so much fun. Phyllis loves getting to play basketball, play Flunkerton. To play games. She wants to be a participant. She does. She was very excited.
对。哦。安吉拉式的傲慢。这绝对是严重的安吉拉式傲慢。关于“帕姆乒乓”，我有一个问题要问你。好吧。这是不是办公室同事第一次当面挑明吉姆和帕姆之间的暗恋？
I felt like, Jenna, I have two note cards here that I felt like we should outline a little bit of the games. Let's do it. Okay. First of all, there are the games that people played that weren't part of the office Olympics, but were the inspiration for Jim. Yeah.
是的。对吧？这是第一次有人说：“哦，我看出怎么回事了。你谁也骗不了。”是的。对。对。而且帕姆在接下来的一整集里对此都超级自我意识过剩。
When he was going around to everyone's like sort of desk area. So Pam, of course, threw, you know, things into Dwight's coffee cup. There was hateball and accounting. There was dunderball and human resources. Stanley said he plays work hard so his kids can go to college. And then Angela Martin says she plays Pampong.
对。所以，然后当然我们在十六分钟二十秒时看到了安吉拉。她在记分。她走过来了。那是她那天唯一玩的游戏。那是她唯一玩的游戏。但随后吉姆发明的实际游戏，吉姆和帕姆，对吧？
Yeah. Oh. Angela sass. That is some serious Angela sass. I have a question for you about Pampong. Okay. Is this the first time that an office coworker has called out the Jim Pam crush?
对。他们发明了这些游戏：第一，飞盘投掷，菲莉丝是那个游戏的赢家。对。第二，你能把多少M&M巧克力豆塞进嘴里？凯文是唯一的。唯一的参与者。唯一的参与者。
Yes. Right? That's the first time someone's like, oh, I see what's happening. You're not fooling anyone. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. And Pam is super self-conscious about it for the rest of the
第三，猜电梯。灵感来自现实生活中的办公室奥运会。瑞安赢了那个。然后我们看到的最后一个游戏是奥斯卡和托比之间的一场完整的咖啡杯接力赛，在迈克尔和德怀特走进办公室时被打断了，我们从未看到那场比赛的结果。好吧，我们其实看到了。我觉得托比的咖啡最后洒出来了。
episode. Yeah. So, and then of course we have Angela at 16 minutes, 20 seconds. She's keeping score. She comes over. That's the only game she's playing that day. That's the only game she's playing. But then the actual games that Jim makes up, Jim and Pam, right?
所以你是，你是。我把冠军判给奥斯卡。你判给奥斯卡。好吧。好吧。但在十七分钟三十二秒时，你的办公桌上挂着两枚奖牌。你有一金一银。
Yeah. They make these up are number one, Flunkerton, Phyllis being the winner of that. Yeah. Number two, how many M&Ms can you put in your mouth? Kevin was the only. Only participants. Only participants.
对。所以我很好奇帕姆赢的是什么。我不知道你是在说我不配拥有我的奖牌，安吉拉。不，排毒。我没有。我只是单纯作为一个粉丝在说：“我想知道，我很好奇我们没能看到的其他游戏是什么。”对。
Three, guess the elevator. Inspired by the real office Olympics. And Ryan won that. And then the final game that we see is this full coffee mug relay between Oscar and Toby and it disrupts when Michael and Dwight come in the office and we never see the outcome of that. Well, we kind of do. I think Toby's coffee is spilling at the end.
很显然是帕姆赢得金牌的某个项目。哦天哪。我只想说。好吧。好吧。安吉拉。也许她在“帕姆乒乓”里赢了一枚金牌。哦，我明白了。
So you're, you're. I'm giving it to Oscar. You're giving it to Oscar. Okay. Okay. But you have two medals hanging on your desk at 17 minutes, 32 seconds. You have a gold and a silver.
我明白你这话的意思了。谢谢。我确实有一个粉丝的问题。凯伦问：你们能把奖牌带回家吗？可以。而且我到现在还留着我的。啊。
Yeah. So I wonder what Pam won for. I don't know you saying I don't deserve my medals, Angela. No, cleanse. I'm not. I'm just merely being a fan saying, I wonder, I wonder what other games we didn't get to see. Yeah.
我的家庭办公室里有一个酸奶盖奖牌，它就挂在我的邓迪奖杯上。而从这一集里，我留着奥斯卡画的安吉拉扮演施虐女王、拉着穿着戏服的凯文和奥斯卡到处走的画。我们保留了各种各样的剧组物品。我们确实留了。我们有点像守财奴，各位。我们开玩笑说总有一天我们要出一本书，把它们都放进去，放在某个我们可以分享的地方。
Well, obviously something where Pam won a gold medal. Oh my God. I just want to say. Okay. All right. Angela. Maybe she won a gold medal at Pampong. Oh, I see.
我觉得我们应该这么做。我也觉得我们应该这么做。我们应该翻翻我们的箱子，把所有这些纪念品和海量的照片分享出来。对。我是说，我们有太多了。太多了。而且我也想这么做。
I see what you've done there. Thank you. I do have a fan question. Karen asked, did you get to take home the medals? Yes. And I still have mine. Aw. I have a yogurt lid medal in my home office and it is hanging on my
我们能终于着手做那件事了吗，拜托，安吉拉？我们能做吗？可以。你们大家会想要这个的，对吧？你们会想要一本记录这些东西的书的。人们会想要吗？就像一本剪贴簿。剪贴簿。
Dundee. And from this episode, I have the drawing Oscar did of Angela as a dominatrix pulling Kevin and Oscar around in costume. We kept all kinds of stuff from the show. We did. We're a little bit of hoarders, guys. Someday we joke that we're going to do a book and put them all in, all somewhere where we can share them.
就像我们那种最佳好友（BFF）剪贴簿。对。对。我觉得我们应该这样做，因为我想在把这些东西弄丢之前把它做出来，好吗？因为我有点担心。我有点担心我的仓库。最后，各位，我不能不聊聊二十分五十三秒的那个场景。那是闭幕式。
I think we should. I think we should too. We should go through our bins and we should share all this memorabilia and our tons of photos. Yeah. I mean, we have so many. So many. And I also want to do it.
我们之前稍微聊过这个，保尔。对。我非常赞同。史蒂夫奉献了一场如此精彩的表演，作为迈克尔，他眼眶含泪。他做出了买公寓的这个重大人生选择。
Can we finally get on that, please, Angela? Can we do that? Yes. You guys would want that, right? You would want a book of this stuff. Do people want that? Like a scrapbook. A scrapbook.
他感受到了来自他的办公室大家庭的这种爱与支持，这种支持他可能从自己的原生家庭里得不到，对吧？办公室大家庭就是他的家庭。他完全情绪激动了。而当我们拍摄时，我们并不知道史蒂夫会做出那种流露感情的选择。所以我们都看着他，他开始眼眶湿润。而我，作为安吉拉·马丁，开始，作为我自己，开始眼眶湿润。
Like our sort of BFF scrapbook. Yeah. Yeah. I think we should because I want to do it before I lose the stuff, okay? Because I'm worried. I'm worried about my shed. Lastly, guys, I cannot not talk about the scene at 20 minutes,
对。太感人了，就是他对自己所饰演的这个人物的真诚刻画。史蒂夫简直太棒了。对。对，当那种情况发生并且那是第一次拍到那个镜头时，保尔随后对我们说：“这就是这个场景的基调。”对。
53 seconds. It's the closing ceremonies. And we talked a little bit about this, Paul. Yeah. And I agree. Steve did such an amazing performance where as Michael, he tears up. He's made this huge life choice to buy a condo.
这就是我们要拍的方式。所以大家只要为迈克尔感到骄傲。就真实地去演。真实地去演。对我来说这很难，因为我觉得安吉拉·马丁当时根本不想参与办公室奥运会。可能觉得这纯粹是在浪费时间。而且可能对迈克尔也没有太多温暖的感情。
He's filling this love and support from his office family that he doesn't get from his family, probably, right? The office family is his family. And he's absolutely emotional. And when we filmed it, we did not know that Steve was going to make that choice to get emotional. And so we're all looking at him and he started to tear up. And I, as Angela Martin started, as myself, started to tear up.
他从办公室这个“家”感受到了那种他在自己家里可能得不到的爱与支持，对吧？办公室的同事就是他的家人。他是真的很动情。当我们拍摄这一幕时，我们并不知道史蒂夫会选择流露出真情实感。所以我们都看着他，他开始眼含泪水。而我，作为安吉拉·马丁，也作为我自己，也开始眼含热泪。
Yeah. It was so moving, just sort of his honest portrayal of this person. And Steve is just amazing. Yeah. Yeah, when that happened and the first take that that happened in, Paul then said to us, this is the direction of this scene. Yeah. This is how we're going to do it.
是的。这太感人了，他对自己所饰角色的这种真诚诠释实在是太动人了。史蒂夫简直太棒了。对的，当那一幕发生时，在拍摄的第一个镜头里，保罗就对我们说，这就是这场戏的方向。是的，我们就是要这么演。
So everyone just be proud of Michael. Just play it real. Play it real. It was hard for me because I feel like Angela Martin did not want to participate in office Olympics. Probably thought this was a waste of time. Also probably doesn't have really a lot of warm feelings towards Michael.
所以大家都为迈克尔感到骄傲吧。就按真实的情感来演。真实地去演。这对我来说很难，因为我觉得安吉拉·马丁其实根本不想参加办公室奥运会。她可能觉得这是在浪费时间。而且她对迈克尔可能也并没有太多温暖的感觉。
But for me as Angela Kinsey, watching my friend Steve do this performance, it was so hard not to get emotional and sort of know the fine line that was me reacting and Angela Martin, how she would react. I teared up when we shot this. I tear up every time I watch it. I also watch this episode three times in preparation for this podcast and I cried every time. Yeah.
但对我来说，作为安吉拉·金西，看着我的朋友史蒂夫进行这场表演，真的很难不被触动，并且很难去界定这是我的真实反应，还是安吉拉·马丁会有什么反应。我们拍摄这一幕时我眼眶湿润了。我每次看都会哭。为了这次播客，我把这一集看了三遍，每一次我都哭了。是的。
Isabel, when she watched it with me, she said, Mommy, he's crying. I said, I know. I know. It was a big moment in his life. These are the things I love about this show. Same. Guys, that's Office Olympics. That is Office Olympics.
伊莎贝尔和我一起看的时候，她说，妈妈，他在哭。我说，我知道，我知道。这是他人生中的一个重要时刻。这就是我喜欢这部剧的地方。我也是。伙计们，这就是《办公室奥运会》。这就是《办公室奥运会》。
Join us next week for The Fire. Yes. You're going to hear all about how Angela was almost carried away by a giant bug. And I might have hit John Krasinski. You did hit John Krasinski. All right. We'll see you next week.
下周请和我们一起收听《火灾》。是的。你们会听到关于安吉拉差点被一只大虫子带走的故事。而且我可能打了约翰·卡拉辛斯基。你确实打了约翰·卡拉辛斯基。好的。我们下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes, Candy Bag, go to Stitcher Premium.com.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听本节目的无广告版本和我们的花絮节目“糖果袋”，请访问 Stitcher Premium.com。
For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用代码：Office。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。